today on the matt wall show politicians
in dc ship 40 billion off to ukraine
while babies in our country don't even
have enough food to eat the priorities
here seem to be wildly out of whack also
the white house explicitly encourages
more illegal protests out of judges
homes the treasury secretary worries
about the economic impact of killing
fewer babies britney spears fans are now
worried about her mental health after
mobilizing get her freed from her
conservatorship perhaps they should have
been more careful what they wished for
in a daily cancellation a local
weatherman is smeared by the national
media as a racist because of something
he tweeted about an nba player but was
the comment actually racist we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
you know right now there are 50 million
kids attending america's public schools
the left isn't even trying to hide it
anymore they have made it clear that
their intention is to indoctrinate the
next generation in their ideology real
world skills like reading writing
arithmetic and american history have
been replaced with social justice gender
confusion test driven instruction in the
classroom thankfully you have a choice
and this is why freedom project academy
was created freedom project academy is
an accredited classical online school
built on judeo-christian values for
students in kindergarten through high
school freedom project academy has taken
the interaction of the traditional
classroom and created an online
atmosphere where students across the
country are instructed by live teachers
in small classes who teach students how
to think not what to think so go to
freedomforschool.com and request your
free information packet today that's
freedomforschool.com and don't forget to
check out their weekly podcast the dr
duke show available on itunes and more
take back control of your kids education
you want to go to freedomforschool.com
again that's
freedomforschool.com today
with our country ravaged by crisis after
crisis and now facing inflation worse
than anything we've seen in my lifetime
in 40 years in fact our leaders in dc
have decided that now is the best time
to ship a little gift basket to ukraine
actually it's a rather large gift basket
and inside among other prizes and
goodies is 40 billion dollars the house
yesterday with the help of a majority of
republicans
along with every democrat of course last
night voted for an improv approved an
additional 40 billion dollars to ukraine
and when we say to ukraine we mean
specifically
to the government of ukraine a
government that happens to be among the
most corrupt in the entire world the
government which is also most
importantly foreign we are sending
billions to a foreign government
billions more i should say is
representative thomas massey points out
this is just the latest bundle of aid
that we've sent to ukraine and when you
add together everything we've sent to
the ukrainian government over the past
six months you find that we have spent
more on ukraine in half a year than
we've spent on building roads and
bridges in our own country over the past
entire year
now do we know
exactly how this money will be spent
will there be any accountability
do we as the american taxpayers funding
these sugar daddy payments have any
ability whatsoever to influence or
determine the manner in which this money
is spent
do we directly benefit from these
expenditures
will giving your money to the ukrainian
government help your family
i mean isn't it a form of taxation
without representation when money is
sent to a government that we as the
taxpayers have no say in or influence
over
the answer to that last question is of
course yes
as to all the rest the answer is no no
no and no so how can this be justified
how can our leaders especially now given
the dire economic straits that our
country is in somehow justify sending
another blank check to some foreign
country 6 000 miles away well nancy
pelosi has an answer to that question
and she found it somehow
in scripture if you can believe it
listen to this
the brutality of putin is not just what
he's doing in ukraine but the impact
that his
that it is having on food for the world
so when you're home thinking what is
this all about just think about when i
was hungry
you fed me in the gospel of matthew
it also was so pleased that mr meeks the
chairman of the foreign affairs
committee was with us because we talked
about sanctions which are a product of
his committee
so this is what happens when you quote
the bible without ever having once in
your life open the book to read it
yourself you might then embarrass
yourself by claiming that when jesus
said feed the hungry he meant that we
should line the pockets of corrupt
foreign bureaucrats politicians and
defense contractors
that's what he meant by the hungary and
we have to do this because as mitch
mcconnell explains the situation in
ukraine is the most important thing
going on in the entire world right now
listen
everyone um i think we all agree the
most
important thing going on in the world
right now is the war in ukraine
i had a chance to call the president
last week and request
that the ukraine package
move
by itself
and quickly
uh he said let me think it over he
called back in
about 15 minutes and agreed that
we need to do this
ukraine only
and quickly i think we're on the path to
getting that done
discussions are underway between the
house and
senate appropriators on the crafting of
the package
it needs to be clean of extraneous
matters
directly related to helping the
ukrainians
uh win the war
ukraine only ukraine first make ukraine
great again
always remember my rule of
bipartisanship which is that if both
parties want to do something and can
actually agree on it
that only means that the idea is so
uniquely terrible that it managed to
appeal to both sides like
if democrats are the only ones who want
to do something it's always a bad idea
if republicans are the only ones who
want to do something it's very often a
bad idea especially if it's the
establishment or the republican party in
dc but if they both together
are looking at each other and saying
yeah this is a great idea guys let's do
it a hundred percent of the time it's a
bad idea
um now mcconnell says that we can all
agree that ukraine is the most important
thing in the world right now
and when he says all he means literally
just the people in that room and
elsewhere in the building
because if you go outside of that room
and you travel say to i don't know the
nearest gas station
you will not find a single person
not a single one who identifies ukraine
as their highest priority
it is a special sickness of american
politicians that they always think the
most important
needs in the world are the needs of
people who are not american
and that is certainly not the way that
most americans see it however
in fact i would have a difficult time
listing all the things that are more
important to me than ukraine because the
list would be far too long
suffice it to say that anything and
everything which directly impacts my
family my community and my countrymen is
more important to me than ukraine
the very existence of ukraine as a
country is not as important to me
it's actually not that important to me
at all in fact
and i'll give you something that is that
is certainly far far more important than
ukraine and which should be at this
point the top priority of every
politician in dc if they weren't busy
figuring out how to make how to make
ukrainian bureaucrats richer and that is
the baby formula shortage there is a
nationwide shortage of baby formula that
has reached crisis levels cnn which has
finally decided to begrudgingly
acknowledge this problem uh reports
today quote
and some of these numbers are just
shocking so listen to this
for months stores nationwide have been
struggling to stock enough baby formula
manufacturers say they're producing at
full capacity and making as much formula
as they can but it's still not enough to
meet current demand the out-of-stock
rate for baby formula hovered between
two percent and eight percent in the
first half of 2021
like right when biden got into office
but began rising sharply last july
between november 2021 and early april
2022 the out-of-stock rate jumped to 31
that rate increased another 9 points in
just three weeks in april and now stands
at 40 percent
in six states iowa south dakota north
dakota missouri texas and tennessee more
than half of baby formula was completely
sold out during the week starting april
24th and although seven states had
between 40 50 of baby formula products
out of stock as of early april 26 states
are now struggling with supply
uh many stores are now as i mentioned
yesterday they're rationing baby formula
some parents report having to drive
hours just to find a single container of
it
and this is a major problem because
and this i think comes maybe as a
surprise to non-parents it certainly it
did surprise me i'll admit um and that
is that breastfeeding is not an easy or
automatic thing
some women are not able to breastfeed at
all for a variety of reasons in many
cases as was the case with our twins
breastfeeding has to be supplemented
with formula to make sure the babies get
all the nutrients they need it's it's
possible to make formula at home but if
you don't do it right
or use the correct ingredients you could
deprive your child of the nutrition that
he needs to grow or even just survive
you know some people trying to dismiss
this problem have just waved their hands
and said well what did people do before
prepackaged baby formula existed
the answer is that lots of babies were
malnourished
and many of them died
that's what people did
the infant mortality rate was
astronomical everywhere in pre-modern
times that had a lot to do with diseases
and the lack of proper medicine in
modern medicine but
also a lack of proper nutrition played a
significant role
so
why is this happening now apologists for
the buy administration have tried to
blame of course everyone and everything
uh but biden and his in his
administration they point to the
pandemic the supply chain
one source of the problem they say they
also note that abbott nutrition which is
a manufacturer baby formula recalled
three of its products because of
possible bacterial contamination
and that happened a few months ago and
that's true
but what they fail to mention is that
the fda a federal agency controlled by
the administration
has made the problem exponentially worse
as always
there is a vast surplus of baby formula
in europe
which could be imported to the us to
help solve this problem but the fda has
made importing much of it illegal
because they have not approved the
european formula despite the fact that
it's perfectly safe and it's used by
millions of parents and consumed by
millions of babies in europe without any
problem
so as usual
bureaucracy walls off potential
solutions to major problems with
regulation and red tape that's a big
part of this story
now of course the fda isn't the only
culprit here
they're simply being as useless onerous
and counterproductive as they always are
and the shortage cannot be blamed
entirely on biden obviously but the
great sin committed by biden and our
other leaders in dc when it comes to
this issue is that they are not focused
on trying to solve it
i mean
we pay the federal government
four trillion dollars a year
so that they can take care of issues
like this
and for all that money that we spend we
should be able to expect that they'll
take care of issues like this
like we are um
a modern industrialized western country
and we spend four trillion dollars a
year on this government
we should not have babies potentially
starving because they don't have enough
formula
but we do because um you know our
politicians they're worried about
ukraine
and about a thousand other things that
should be much further down the list of
priorities if those things even make it
on the list at all
as i pointed out yesterday we've heard
we've heard more from the federal
government about the student loan crisis
than we have about this crisis
they have greater concern for graduate
students whining about their bills
than for infants who don't have enough
food to eat
infantilized adults taking priority over
actual infants
just as ukrainian bureaucrats take
priority over infants in this country
there are many different comparisons
that put this into perspective
and all in all the picture here is that
our politicians have many priorities
none of them include doing the job that
we actually put them there
to do
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you ever notice it when stores are
trying to sell products they know next
to nothing about maybe they push the
shoes that are shoes that are most
popular rather than the ones that
actually fit your feet well i like
rockauto.com because what they know is
auto parts and all they sell is auto
parts and related tools rock auto is a
family business founded by automotive
engineers over 20 years ago their
original goal was and still is to make
auto parts available and affordable so
customers can keep their daily drivers
and classic classic cars safely on the
road every day rockauto.com's online
parts catalog is uniquely easy to use
you quickly see all the parts available
for your specific car or your viewer
truck whatever you drive there are
photos specs and installation tips to
help you pick the best parts to meet
your vehicle's needs rockauto.com will
not only have the part but usually
they'll give you several trusted brands
to choose from rock otto's kits are also
popular because they bundle together all
the parts needed for a successful repair
you don't get halfway through installing
a timing belt to discover you need
another pulley professional mechanics
and do-it-yourselfers always pay the
same reliably low prices with rockow.com
so go to rockauto.com get the brake
shocks carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts or any other part you
need be sure to check walsh in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that i sent you
and the other thing to keep in mind too
by the way when you hear about the you
know as as we're now starting finally to
hear about the baby formula shortage
problem and this is a problem that's
been brewing for for months and it's
been a problem for months and we're just
starting to hear about it because the
media has no
has no choice now but to report on it
and um along with uh the the recall and
they're gonna blame that and already
explained how you know
that yeah some of that goes back to the
fda though because they're they're
preventing us from solving that problem
but the other thing is this this this uh
claim that well it's because of the
pandemic
the pandemic related supply chain issues
we'll always remember when you hear that
as an explanation or an excuse for any
of the problems we're suffering through
right now including the baby formula
shortage when they hear it well it's
pandemic related no it's not pandemic
related
there is no reason why covid itself
would have caused a supply chain problem
there is no reason why covet itself the
virus would have stopped us from having
enough baby formula
no that all stems from the policies that
were put in place in this country and in
countries across the world
it was the decision
by politicians many of them still in
power in dc right now to shut the world
down
for no reason ostensibly because of
covet that's what it comes back to it's
not pandemic it's not covid it's them
and their policies
so in the end it does all come back to
them
and speaking of them uh jen pasaki is
not exactly
discouraging more illegal protests at
the supreme court which are again we
should continue to note illegal federal
crimes you cannot do this it's actually
not
everyone when you see this footage and
you think well how is that legal to
to gather an angry mob outside of a
supreme court justice house
try to get them to change their mind
about something how's that well the good
news is it's actually not legal the bad
news is that um the people in charge of
enforcing the law are not going to do it
and in fact they're going the other way
let's know what jen pasake said
yesterday listen
i know that there's an outrage right now
i guess about
protests that have been peaceful to date
and we certainly continue to encourage
that outside of judges homes and that's
the president's position
we certainly continue to encourage that
what is that
protest
now
they're going to explain that away by
saying well she meant encourage it to be
peaceful
well one way or another you are
encouraging quote peaceful protests
when they're actually not peaceful at
all
okay they don't they don't need to start
throwing molotov cocktails i mean
they've already started they've already
done that uh
pro-abortion militants and terrorists
have already been throwing molotov
cocktails but um and and it's
and there's there's no question that
eventually it's gonna get to the point
of actual physical violence but it's not
really
peaceful when number one it's against
the law
and number two the intention behind the
quote unquote protest is to intimidate
not only that but to intimidate a judge
to change his decision
on a case that
it's hard to call that peaceful
because there's always there is the the
threat of violence
which is bubbling always under the
surface here
that's the context
okay
that's the uh that's the implication of
all of this
the only reason that you should that's
the only reason that you show up the
only reason that you show up to
somebody's house i mean it's one thing
if you're
picketing outside of a government
facility if you want to go outside of
the supreme court itself and protest
well you have the right to do that
but the only reason that you go to
somebody's house
is to send the message that number one
we know where you live
and
number two therefore you are not safe
so no matter what the protesters do when
they get there it is not peaceful and
gen pasaki and by administration knows
that but they are openly now you want to
talk about calling for an insurrection
they are openly calling for their
supporters to break federal law
to influence a supreme court decision
what you just heard from jen pasaki
is goes way further
than anything that donald trump said on
january 6th
because in fact donald trump did not at
any point tell anyone to break the law
uh he didn't say oh invade the capitol
building
but do it peacefully
i mean if he had done that then it's i
mean it's game over he told he told them
to go break the law
that's exactly what we just heard from
the white house there
yeah break federal law but do it
peacefully
uh meanwhile we've got nancy pelosi we
just heard from her but she was also uh
talking about you know she is of course
outraged by the fact that um
that more babies are going to live and
not be killed
and here she is reminiscing about the
republican party of old which was she
says
you know among other things
pro-abortion listen
the fossil fuel
industry they weigh in so significantly
i mean how could it be
that nobody on the senate side cares
and the senate cares about
climate some of them do and they talk
about it when it comes to the votes
it just isn't there they're just not
there so rather than saying well we have
to defeat them no let's just try to
persuade them
i want the republican party to take back
the party take it back to where you were
where you cared about a woman's right to
choose you cared about the environment
and
here i am nancy pelosi saying this
country needs a strong republican party
and we do
not a cult but a strong republican
[Applause]
yes let's go back to when the republican
party was pro-abortion when was that
exactly i mean she's right in a sense
that um
the republican party has historically
been
if not actively pro-abortion uh at least
submissive on the issue and still
largely is
and that's really what she's calling for
is just hey look
this is always the message from
democrats which is we can get along
and and we can all be friends or at
least act like it as long as you do
exactly what i want you to do
just stay out of my way cooperate with
everything that that i want to do and uh
and and
there will be no problem we have
bipartisanship
in fact in that case
now we have janet yellen who's the um
treasury secretary and she was
testifying yesterday in front of a
senate committee about
uh the effects of abortion on the
economy they brought her in to talk
about uh how it's gonna how it might
hurt the economy
if we stop killing babies or not don't
not not stop killing them but rather if
we slow the rate by which we are
murdering babies it will it will maybe
hurt the economy she's very concerned
about that let's listen to that
if
the draft of the court's majority
holding in roe versus way
is the actual decision what impact will
the loss of abortion access mean
economically for when
well i believe that eliminating the
right of women to make decisions about
when and whether to have children would
have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
roe v wade and access to reproductive
health care including abortion
helped lead to increased labor force
participation it enabled
many women to finish school that
increased their earning potential it
allowed women to plan and balance their
families and careers and research also
shows that it had a favorable impact on
the well-being and earnings
of of children
all right so we heard we heard from her
there she's concerned that abortion will
uh will hurt the economy because it'll
stop women from participating in the
workforce we have to be we have to kill
babies in order to help the economy this
is again we we have to remind ourselves
this is what that's eugenics that's what
eugenics is
um
you know getting rid of the undesirables
the the you know the
the the people that are
slowing everything down bringing the
economy down just just exterminate them
for the sake of the economy for this
very kind of utilitarian
reason
that's just a
form of eugenics really
and on top of being morally
atrocious
which it is for so many reasons
number one being you're totally
disregarding
uh
and ignoring the humanity and dignity
and worth of the child
but also it's again this message to
women which is that you have to choose
between your child and your career
you you can be
successful professionally or you can be
a mother
and you have to choose one of the other
and the right choice in fact is to
choose your career and kill your child
that's the message which is not so
subtly embedded in what you just heard
there
and our response to that by the way
i think there's a little bit of uh
nuance here that we have to keep in mind
because i think sometimes conservatives
will respond to claims like that by
saying oh that's that's absurd you can
you know you could be a mother you can
have your kid and you can have you can
have everything you can have all the
financial success in the world lots of
times uh people will use someone like
amy coney barrett as an example i mean
she's got she's adopted kids she's had
she's had
you know but she has biological kids she
has what is it five or six kids now and
she is on the supreme court i mean she's
had
enormous
professional success she's made it all
the way to the very pinnacle of her
career while being a mother to five or
six kids
um and they use that kind of as an
example and that's
that's true and that's
a great point to bring up
but we should also acknowledge that very
often there are going to be trade-offs
and if you just if you have kids
uh
there are exceptions to this there's no
you know there's no guarantee i mean you
you kind of make your own path in life
but
yeah when you have kids um
there's a finance certainly a financial
sacrifice that goes with that
there's sacrifices that you make in your
lifestyle
that's true
and i don't think we wanna we're not
hiding from that we shouldn't hide from
that
i mean we shouldn't respond to that by
acting like oh having a kid will have no
impact at all financially and everything
will be fine
no i know that i know that's the case in
my own family anyone with kids you know
that
you know when you have kids we have four
kids you you end up living a a a more a
more humble life than you otherwise
maybe could have afforded to live you're
gonna have you're gonna have uh less
spending money you have less of ability
to go on nice vacations and all these
kinds of things i mean you're you are
making sacrifices
but the sacrifice is worth it
i mean what you get in exchange for that
is is a family is fulfillment
um is
purpose
uh is love uh is
legacy you know you you have
something you're going to leave behind
when you finally are released from this
uh
mortal coil
so yeah the sacrifices are there but
that's what you get instead
because as it turns out
we are not all just cogs in the economic
machine
which is the interesting thing because
on the left you know they also they
pretend to be anti-capitalist and all
this kind of stuff but at the same time
they make us all seem like that's all we
are
and especially if you're a woman the
greatest thing you could hope to be in
life is you know to get a position in
management at some corporation
to have a nice cubicle or even better an
office somewhere in an office building a
skyscraper like that's that is the
pinnacle of human existence say the
alleged anti-capitalists
it's not when you decide to have kids
when you have a family you get something
much greater and deeper than that and
you and there are sacrifices but
anything in life worth having there are
going to be sacrifices that come with
it all right let's go to this from the
daily mail this is a trend now i want
you to
i'm going to read
this article
as it was written
okay because this that's
really the main point i want to make
about this is the way that this is
written okay
from a daily mail it says a transgender
mother
who forced the seven-year-old daughter
she fathered to engage in child
pornography at her new jersey home has
been jailed for 25 years without parole
along with three accomplices
um
marina vols previously named matthew was
sentenced on friday alongside another
transgender woman ashley romero
previously named adam and two other
offenders sean allen and dulcina
neko 21 vols 32 rand ran a quote
family-owned transgender pornography
production studio
specializing in amateur bdsm and taboo
fetish content
from her home in franklin township
um
and
it goes further into the details which
i'm not even going to read because it's
totally horrifying i mean what they did
to this child is just beyond
description and the fact that we're
i mean 25 years in jail for
sexually torturing your child is
that's a slap on the wrist i mean you
might as well give him
you might as well just put them in
county lock up for for a day
in comparison to what the penalty ought
to be
i mean just think about that you in the
united states of america this is someone
sexually
torturing and exploiting their own child
and they're going to see the outside of
a jail cell
in fact he's going to be you know 25
years
they say without the possibility of
parole we'll see about that
even if he spends every day of that in
jail
um you know he'll be out by the age of
uh late 50s early 60s
no this should be
you're
convicted of it and then the very next
day we
you know take you up to the uh to the
gallows and we take care of the problem
public execution would be really the
best solution here for somebody like
that
but on top of that
um
we are respecting the pronouns and
self-identification
of a child rapist who raped and sexually
tortured their their his own child
and that's how we end up with a with a
phrase like
she
fathered
which would be bad enough
being as it's completely incoherent
but we're finding that phrase in this
article about this person
because we're afraid about we're afraid
of hurting his feelings
raped and sexually abused his own child
and we're afraid that if he sees the
daily mail article his feelings will be
hurt
it's total total uh moral insanity all
right this is from the new york post it
says stanford university has launched a
hate crime investigation after a noose
was found hanging from a tree as at a
residence hall in an email to students
and staff university officials said
campus safety authorities immediately
removed the noose and retained it as
evidence
the
official at the university says we
cannot state strongly enough that a
noose is a reprehensible symbol of
anti-black racism and violence that will
not be tolerated on our campus it is the
moral responsibility of those with any
knowledge of this incident to come
forward
now i'm only reading this story because
i want to go
usually i ignore these stories until it
is inevitably revealed that it's a hoax
so i just i'm gonna go on the record
right now and say this is either a hoax
now this is there's there's two
possibilities
um
one is that it's just a straight-up hoax
probably most likely one the other one
is that and and often we find in these
kinds of stories it turns out that it
was uh you know it's like a tire tire
swing that somebody misinterpreted
or a garage door pull famously like at
nascar
so i'm gonna go on the record right now
and i give it about a week until we get
the we get the meek quiet sort of little
update from the police saying oh yeah it
turns out that uh never mind just forget
about this whole story
and despite that fact despite the fact
that these hoaxes are so common
that when you read the story you already
know for near 100 certainty that it is a
hoax
despite that
when they find the quote noose uh the
statement immediately says oh it's a
symbol of anti-black racism
i ask again has there actually been
a real authentic case in the last
in this century
in this century has there been a real
authentic case of a of an anti-black
racist a white person hanging a noose
somewhere as an as a symbol of racism
has has that happened at all anywhere
this century
i'm not aware of a single case of it
and i highly doubt that this incident at
stanford in california will will be the
uh the first such authentic example
in in the past century at least
but one thing we can be sure is that uh
the fbi federal government they're gonna
be on the case here
they sent what was it 20 agents to
investigate the garage door pull in
bubba wallace's garage so how many are
they going to send to stanford
while they have crazed mobs
violating federal law and hunting down
supreme court justices uh they don't
have time to deal with that they're
going to be over in stanford looking
into this uh tire swing or you know
whatever it was
all right another story this from daley
wire says britney spears elicited
concern among her fans after posting a
series of full front naked pictures on
instagram on monday
the photos show spears totally nude
except for her hands attempting to cover
her breasts and a small heart covering
her genitals spears who has two teenage
son is currently pregnant with a child
wrote quote photo jump dump of the last
time i was in mexico before there was a
baby inside me
why the heck do i look 10 years younger
on vacation so this is something that
britney spears is doing apparently a lot
she just posts these
these naked pictures all the time she's
a 40 year old woman by the way
and um but the story here is that now
her fans are concerned and so now i
guess originally when she started doing
this they were kind of into it but now
people are getting concerned about it
they're like you're a 40 year old woman
you're
you know you got all the money in the
world what do you do what is this what
are you doing
and they're very worried about her
mental health
which
gives me an opportunity you know how
hesitant i am to do it you know how much
i hate to do this
but it does give me an opportunity that
i have to take advantage of to say
i mean i told you so
what if britney spears is actually
insane though
like we seem to have ruled out that
possibility
if she's
if she's actually in i don't know i
don't know what her mental health can
situation is
um
but
if she's actually
psychotic or insane or something
then that's probably why the
conservatorship was put in place to
begin with it doesn't justify everything
that's been done under the guiseley
conservatorship uh necessarily but
that's why it's there so
all the protesters
who for months or years now some of them
showing up at the courtroom demanding
take the conservative ship off like do
you know something about britney spears
spears's mental health situation
that the people involved in this case
the judges and everyone don't know what
information do you have
because what you're saying is no just
take it off
but what if she really is not competent
is not able to handle her own affairs
back when the whole free britney
movement was happening i did address it
one time on the show
and i and i just wanted to remind
everybody who i guess they they saw a
netflix documentary
and because of the documentary they
decided that uh bernie spears she
shouldn't be in a conservatorship
like that was to see this documentary
that was enough for them to make a a
judgment about britney spears's
psychological state
and to declare that no she's perfectly
capable of taking care of herself
she's not a threat to herself or others
and they all got that from a documentary
like 90 minutes that was all they needed
and my point was um
i i i i wouldn't i wouldn't
i don't know how you know that like slow
down a little bit
um
there are cases where people are not
psychologically fit
and who do need conservatorships because
they are a danger to themselves and
others like that does exist in the world
and how do we know that britney spears
doesn't fall into that category
how do we know that exactly
because although i admit i haven't
followed her career that closely what i
do know about bernie spears is that
she's had multiple public mental
breakdowns
and i also know
that she lost custody of her kids in
california and as a woman
to begin with in any court to lose
custody of your kids is almost
impossible to do it in california i mean
you have to be
psychotically insane and dangerous it is
very very difficult as a woman to lose
complete custody of your kids especially
in a court in california
and she did
and on top of that not only a woman
california and rich and famous and she
lost custody of her kids
that's actually all as a common sense
kind of guy that's all i need to know
that's i don't need to know anything
else
i i already know you've got serious
serious problems
if if that happened to you in your
situation
but all the um all the fans got together
said free brittany take her out of the
out of the conservatorship now look if
the argument all along was
um
we don't think she should be in a
conservatorship under her father
but someone else should be in charge of
it then that's a different again i still
wouldn't
there would still be a question about
how you could possibly make that
judgment as a person in the peanut
gallery who has no intimate familiarity
with the issue you don't know britney
spears you don't know her father you
don't know anything you haven't seen the
mental health evaluations you have you
don't know any of that so how could you
possibly make the determination but
that's a different argument
and um as much as her dad's been
villainized
i i would say he almost certainly mostly
deserves it just based on the fact that
he
you know sent his 16 year old daughter
off to become a sex symbol i mean he has
his 16 year old daughter in the 90s
dressed as a catholic school girl
singing you know hit me baby one more
time so
that already tells me that you're a
terrible father so that i'm i'm on board
with if you want to say he's a terrible
guy fine
but that wasn't the argument the
argument was well let's just free her
completely
and now the people that were in that
movement are saying i don't know she
seems to be kind of crazy well yeah
that's that's yeah generally that that's
how you end up you lose custody of your
kids you end up with a conservative it's
because you're crazy
that's that's how that works
so nicely done
everybody
give yourselves a pat on the back let's
get to our daily or rather to our
comment section
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right what we got here so jesse says
i'm a little triggered by the girl in
today's cancellation she attributed
crocs to depression crocs are cool
comfortable and stylish they're also
good for mowing lawns and grilling uh no
i'm going to say my judgment call here
is that crocs are not acceptable
if you're going for the lazy ugly
footwear thing
then socks and sandals are what you want
to go soccer sandals are totally
acceptable in really any
circumstance and so that's where you
want to go but i'm going to say no to
the crocs unfortunately um
another comment says matt's next show
matt doing a gut-wrenching interpretive
dance on the left's latest foibles
that's when i get to a million
subscribers okay i get to tell you this
right now and you know that when i make
promises like this i always keep them i
get to a million subscribers on youtube
and i will do an interpretive dance to
express my gratitude
take that to the bank
uh
let's see lynette says i was under the
impression that the phrase it's okay to
not be okay was not intended to
encourage succumbing to your situation
but rather acknowledging that your
situation is tough and that instead of
pretending you're okay you should
identify what's wrong and work to
improve your situation
i mean that may be
one way to interpret that cliche of it's
okay to not be okay
but that's not
you know that's
that's not the way that phrase is often
used
maybe that's how it was originally
intended that's not how it's often used
these days my issue with it is that it's
used as a way of saying
just like we saw in the video the tick
tock video
of the woman saying she was depressed
and so she does you know she she doesn't
brush her teeth she doesn't practice
good hygiene she doesn't care
and she put the video out there because
she wanted to be applauded for that and
she wanted to be affirmed in that kind
of laziness and just sort of giving up
and not caring about things
so the way the way the phrase is used in
a in a way that's very much connected to
that kind of attitude of well hey just
kind of just kind of live in it
don't aim up don't try to overcome
in fact
it's considered offensive these days if
somebody says they have
especially if they're struggling with
something psychologically they say
they're depressed
to suggest
that there's anything they could do
or should do
you know to take control to to uh
you know to improve their situation
psychologically
that that's offensive to suggest that
i mean if you're to say something oh
you're depressed well you know here's
some things maybe you could try to do
that might make you feel a little better
and might improve your situation in life
you know might might help you see things
from a different perspective
unless all you're allowed to do is say
well here's some drugs take those
but anything beyond that is considered
offensive
uh and finally lynette says it's pretty
funny how matt's germaphobia completely
vanished in the wake of covid
yeah it was something i was noticing
about myself recently too is because
before covid
i i admitted to being you know basically
kind of a germaphobe um and so you would
think that if anyone would
start wearing the mask and all that i'd
like i would be in that category as
someone who's you know was worried about
germs but um
i'm actually after through when coveted
started through covet and now i'm a lot
less worried about germs than i ever was
before so i went in the exact opposite
direction of i think a lot of other
people
and i think that's because on one hand i
had the germaphobia going on but on the
other hand i have the kind of contrarian
part of myself and those two things were
very much at war as soon as as soon as
cove started and the contrarianism won
out
which i think is a
is i take that as a success story i
think
well you know there are very few social
events that i will willingly subject
myself to let alone enjoy myself out but
backstage live happens to be one of them
not that i
i'm not really willing either i mean i
have to go but still um i do enjoy
backstage lives and i think you'll enjoy
it too so here's your chance to join me
and the daily wire crew for backstage
live on june 29th at the historic reiman
auditorium in downtown nashville
tennessee we've been on a huge winning
streak from suing the federal government
to
you know to stop their tyrannical
vaccine mandate to announcing our 100
million dollar challenge to woke disney
with dw kids uh also we have you you may
not have heard the best-selling
children's book as well uh that makes
this the perfect time to get together
and celebrate so come sit listen and
marvel at me ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew clavin and daily wire god king
jeremy boring for our biggest live event
of the year tickets go on sale tomorrow
at 10 a.m central time for daily wire
all access members and 12 hours later
for the general public if you're not an
all access member don't miss out head
over to dailywire.com subscribe and
become an all access member today the
other wire backstage live at the ryman
in nashville on june 29th see you there
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have many cancellations to hand
out all revolving around a local fox
weatherman in memphis named joey
sullipec
now why do we need to talk about a
weatherman in memphis i mean what could
he possibly have done to warrant
discussion well according to the media
he did a tweet not just any tweet but a
racist tweet indeed the headlines and
there are a lot of headlines about this
weatherman's tweet all agreed that the
tweet was racist and that he is racist
and that he likely holds clan meetings
in his basement every tuesday just to
give you an idea here are some of the
headlines i'm
just reading a few memphis
meteorologists under fire over racist
draymond green tweet
local tv meteorologist memphis sparks
furor with racist comments about
warriors draymond green
memphis tv station promises
investigation after meteorologists sends
racist tweet about warriors draymond
green
draymond green is the target of memphis
meteorologist rachel slur
and then fox 13 tv weatherman makes
stunningly racist comment about draymond
green
now you'll notice that none of these
headlines use the word alleged or
purported or possible
if they use any qualifier at all it's
stunning
they simply assert that he used a racial
slur and that's the end of it no further
discussion necessary
but if you're wondering what the man
actually said as if such a detail even
matters anymore here's the new york post
article it says a memphis based
meteorologist is under investigation by
his employer for using a racial slur in
a tweet about warriors star draymond
green amid the grizzlies warriors
playoff series fox 13 memphis chief
meteorologist joey sullipec who is white
tweeted the following after game three
get ready for this
uh chew on this draymond runs his
knuckle-dragging open mouth all game
long but mild-mannered kyle anderson
disputes one call and gets ejected next
level jackassery
and then it says sulpic reportedly
deleted the tweet after facing backlash
and he later deleted his entire twitter
account so
that's it
did you spot the racism
probably not seeing as how he didn't say
anything even remotely racially charged
he used the term knuckle dragging to
describe green that's a common
expression
a kind of cliched insult often applied
to people of all different races and
meant to imply that they are as the
oxford dictionary defines the term a
stupid or loutish person
the dictionary makes no mention of any
racial connotation much less does it say
that the term is a racial slur
in fact it has never in my life even
occurred to me to interpret knuckle
dragger in a racist way
and it's still not immediately clear to
me why it would be racist aside from the
simple fact that it's an insult and we
live in a culture so incredibly stupid
that literally any insult of a black
person is immediately assumed to be
racist
but is there more behind it than that
here's an article on the sports news
site marca.com and it provides this
explanation this is what they say
the term knuckle dragger has long been
used by bigots to describe an angry
black man it is meant to compare them to
a large and enraged ape such as a
gorilla
wait what since when has knuckle dragger
meant that
i have literally not once in my entire
life ever heard anyone use it in that
context
in fact as is so often the case in these
kinds of situations you would have to be
extremely racist to actually see the
term as racist
if you hear knuckle dragger and
immediately think oh he must be saying
that black people are apes
then it's you who harbors deeply racist
thoughts and ideas within yourself
that's what's known as projecting
ironically we see again how the alleged
racist villain is actually being
penalized for not being racist
the weatherman is so not racist that it
never so much has crossed his mind to
interpret the term in a racist way he
insulted draymond green the same way
that he would insult anybody else
he treated draymond green as as equal
he didn't take his race into
consideration one way or another and for
that his entire career and his life will
be destroyed
and on that note his employer released a
statement shortly after the non-racist
racist tweet went viral saying during
saturday's memphis grizzlies game
meteorologist joey sulipek tweeted a
comment that does not reflect the values
of fox 13. we take this matter very
seriously and we'll take appropriate
action pending a full investigation
translation he's gone
and i'll never work in the industry ever
again
powerful people in the nba have already
set out to make sure
of that part of it green's coach the
leftist goober steve kerr actually
addressed the tweet during his post-game
press conference and here's what he said
does it surprise me that a weatherman
would tweet a slur at draymond
in 2022 not in the slightest bit this is
this is america this is this is how we
operate
a slur like is that so we're going with
that now
so we could call it the k word
we're gonna get bleeped out if you say
knuckle dragger now
and kerr once again bravely speaking out
about the important issues of our time
such as a weatherman's tweet
steve steve carr he loves to give his
opinion and run his knuckle-dragging
mouth about many subjects that is unless
you ask him about the nba's relationship
with china that's when he suddenly gets
very shy
he'll bravely denounce a weatherman in
memphis but as for the communist
government of china which his company is
in business with he has much less to say
nothing at all to say in fact
now be that as it may kurt is right
actually
he says that this is what america is and
uh and this is what we we do here and
he's correct um that this is what we do
here at least it's what he does here
along with his leftist compatriots and
the media
what they do is entertain themselves and
advertise their own faux virtue and
exercise their cultural power by
destroying the lives of random hapless
patsies like this weatherman
much like they did with the okay sign
they've now simply invented
a racial slur out of whole cloth
they've decided arbitrarily that knuckle
dragger is racist anybody who uses it in
the future or who use it in the past
because these rules could be enforced
retroactively of course
must face the consequences your intent
doesn't matter
they will determine your intent
they will decide
why you said what you said
they get to assign motivation and
meaning to your to your statements after
the fact
does that can be any discussion about it
they will tell you what you meant
and you will accept it
at least if you're foolish and
self-destructive you'll accept it and as
far as that goes solopec is uh trying to
kind of have his cake and eat it too as
far as the apologies go this is a common
mistake that people in this situation
make before deleting his social media he
issued a statement that attempts to
defend himself against the racism charge
while still apologizing for it so he
tweeted anyone who knows me knows what i
am race is never an issue to me
to anybody who was offended i apologize
but there was no ill intent
well of course there was no ill intent
obviously you didn't mean it in a racist
way we know you didn't mean it that way
because the term is in fact not a racial
slur we also know you didn't mean it
that way because even if you were a
raging racist you wouldn't set your life
and career on fire by advertising the
fact on twitter
well that's another thing that's always
left out of these conversations of you
know someone says something oh it was
racist
like in this fantasy world where this
guy's racist why would he say that
so you're saying he's not only racist
but he's psychotic on top of it
because in order to to be a a person
anywhere but especially a public figure
with any kind of platform and to say
something intentionally racist
that he's racist against black people as
a white person of course we know if
you're saying racist people things about
white people that you can totally get
away with it but to do it the other way
you you would not only have to be racist
but you would also have to be a psycho
you would have to be a lunatic
setting your whole life on fire for
no personal benefit
so we all know that's not what happened
here everyone who's pretending to be
offended knows that um the people in the
media writing all of these headlines
defaming him they all know this
steve kerr knows it
nobody's hurt
nobody's offended
and even if they are offended who cares
joey you didn't do anything wrong
there's nothing to apologize for by
apologizing you admit guilt even while
in the next breath denying guilt you
have to pick a lane and the lane you
pick should be the one where you punch
the cry bullies in the mouth and tell
them to get lost
so here's a statement you should have
issued joe you should have said
i called draymond green a knuckle
dragger because i wanted to imply that
he's stupid and obnoxious which he is
the same could be said about the
outraged mob lying about me and calling
the racist i do not believe that any of
you drama queens and phonies are
actually offended and whether you are or
aren't i do not apologize god bless
that's the correct response
in fact draymond green himself
interestingly reacted to the apology on
instagram after the game by saying don't
apologize stand on it
now in context he didn't mean this as
actual encouragement or advice his real
point was simply to amplify the story so
as to further ruin celipe's life but
however insincere his advice was it was
also solid
he's right don't apologize stand on it
never bow to the knuckle draggers in the
cancel mob
let them know that it is not you
but rather they
who are
finally canceled
i'll leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike cormina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. the white house encourages protests
outside the supreme court justice's
homes the treasury secretary warns that
if we don't abort as many babies we
might not make as much money and america
undergoes a shortage of baby formula
check it out on the michael knowles show